d'accord par là OK
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours j'en fais la vie et very
bad trip heureusement que la musique
existe
en avoir des bons
[Musique]
en plus ça horrible oui ah oui donc ça
c'est ça de toute façon toutes les
explications politiques de ce genre de
question me tromper Dieu donc voilà
je pense pas que ça serait forcément
mieux il faut peut-être pas pire
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est marrant parce que j'ai qu'on a dit
l'inverse il y a 20 ans donc non je
pense que c'est plutôt le rock et jazz
comme musique classique et patrimoniale
c'est déjà le cas d'ailleurs
[Musique]
ben parce que c'est festival où il y a
le plus de découverte du total vous
pouvez vous retrouver face à un groupe
métal japonais un groupe électro
bizarroïde bulgare enfin je sais pas
c'est c'est voilà c'est le truc le plus
dépaysant le plus exotique le plus le
plus inattendu voilà ouais
en route parce que ça me passe par la
tête c'est une aujourd'hui ce qu'il t'a
dit est-ce que j'ai découverte ce qui
est génial le New York et fais tu fais
des choses entre jazz-électro mets la
musique avec cette technique vocale du
Pakistan qui est merveilleuse
[Musique]